The opening scene of classic,
the Terminator immediately aligns its
audience with the films may feet men
versus machine.
This fee,
rum stroud's entire movie as calories
and a German etr or sent back in time to
duke it out over Sour O'connor's life.
Both men and machine are fighting for
their very existence.
One is trying to killed a mater of
mankind,
savior walls.
[inaudible] seeks to protect her from
harm.
The Co finance roof,
the film Arriann pictures known for
classics such as Amadeus and two
didn't think very highly of the story
and reportedly only perceived the film
as a low budget vehicle to make some
quick money.
Even James Cameron wasn't old at certain
off the potential of the film
Terminator One was,
was uh,
like a hallucination for me.
I was making my first,
my first picture.
I had no idea it was really going to be
a success.
I mean,
when I,
when I wrote it,
I probably thought it has stood the
chance of being a success.
I wrote it that way on purpose,
you know,
but you never really believed that,
that it's going to happen or that it can
happen.
Arielle and picture saw in the
terminator is straight forward action
but field to see what lay hidden beneath
all the onscreen violence or as the
terminator himself explains it.
I always felt that this,
this was more than the ordinary action
film and it was more than a special
effects from and uh,
or like with some thought was just a b
movie.
In fact,
I think the story is so solid and so
good and it has so many interesting
messages there and it is also
entertaining and so they will have a
broad appeal
because when we look past the surface
level,
another more encompassing theme revealed
itself,
religion versus technology,
the human spirit versus the program
mine.
Cause as the story moves into La of
1984,
you might expect to see it widely
contracting world from the post nuclear
wasteland from the star of the movie.
However,
director James Cameron decided to make
la of the ADC gritty,
gray and arguably hostile place.
Fuck you asshole.
Of course
human guy and is still very much alive
and in control button is already
becoming apparent that the world is in
decline.
New Technologies such as widespread use
of color tvs,
board will,
cassette players and techno music.
I've invaded both the private as well as
the public space as people seem to be in
the kind of trends oblivious to the
world around them.
An example is ginger's obsession with
her music player.
She's dancing around the house,
stuck in her own world.
First she doesn't hear the ring of her
phone,
then she doesn't hear Sarah calling her
name,
gender,
it's matte and the first time,
well,
another example is the club scene.
Where do people dancing are completely
oblivious to the and Fred and even in to
the existence of our three main
characters in general.
No one even as much as glances at the
massive terminator as he handed it to
club and even security is slow to react.
The people of La are not only oblivious,
they're also seen to be egotistical and
apathetic.
The police officers don't seem to care
about an act of serial killer
systematically terminating all the sour
conners in town.
Are sure there's a point to all of this.
It is only when confronted with
potential bad press did they decide to
take action hitting me.
The press is going to be short stroking
and all over the place.
Oh,
one day pattern together.
I hate the weird ones.
Even the people whose job it is to
listen to you and help out or is it only
seems to care about themselves choice.
The psychiatrist tasked with analyzing
Carl Sanity isn't really listening to
him.
Yeah,
but it's actually just thinking of how a
story could elevate his own career
surrounded by living tissue.
How right.
This is great stuff.
I could make a career out of this guy
and later on when the terminators run
over by a truck,
you might expect the driver to call for
help,
but alas,
that's good addict.
Good.
Someone Murray's says that has become
very hard to spot a Cyborg.
It is not only because they look like
us,
but mainly because when we lose our own
humanness,
we are starting to act like den.
Fuck you,
ass whore Sarah and you only ones who
exhibit the traits that human kind and
terminators seems to have lost.
They show compassion to each other and
animals alike.
I came across time for you,
sir.
Have you
always have me
disgusting?
Sarah's almost naive innocence stands in
stark contrast to the world and the
people around her,
her worth to the world,
dramatically shifts from a clumsy
waitress to the mater of mankind.
Savior.
You could even argue that Sarah Connor
is an essence,
the biblical Maria,
her innocence and humanities Cetera,
apart from our fellow human beings,
her friend Ginger even acknowledges her
divine worth better than mortal man
deserves and ironically she gets
impregnated by somewhat immortal
character because even though rees dies
in the end,
the paradoxical loop has been created
and we'll make sure that this event will
keep repeating itself forever.
God,
a person could go crazy thinking about
this.
Ultimately,
she will give birth to John Connor or
Jesus Christ who will bring salvation to
mankind,
who will wake us up right before our own
extinction.
Robert McKee calls this grove symbolic
progression.
We start a story with actions,
locations,
and roles.
The represent only themselves,
but a truly great film lists to tell him
to the next level.
Exposivity from the particular to the
universal,
from the specific to the archival
besides the story of Jesus Christ and
the key fines and the terminator echoes
the ancient archetype of the maze.
The mythological battle between
[inaudible] and the minutes are,
and indeed most of the action of the
film takes place in corridors,
hallways,
alleyways and the like.
The freedom of space in the terminator
is limited.
Even the chase scene on the highway,
it takes place in a tunnel.
It closed off environment source.
So James Cameron shows us stories that
have been taught throughout the ages to
confront us with fears of what lies
ahead.
Determinator franchise has survived up
until now,
and this might partly be because it's
subject is now more relevant than ever.
The majority of the world owns a
smartphone.
Technology literally surrounds us and
changes our perception of the world.
Hopes and fears of the future.
Invention of ai have entered the public
arena.
James Cameron for saw a dark future for
humanity with the terminator,
but also provided us with hope of
changing the outcome.
Silver dust ultimately defeat
determinator by working together with
the machines of her own time.
Yet the front of Doomsday remains.
There's a storm coming.
I know.
So next time when you don't understand
why a certain film has done so well,
look at the progression.
Look at the archetypes,
because every great new story is often
the product of an old one.
I tell you,
I owe him that.
Maybe it'll help if he,
you know that in a few hours that we had
together,
we left a lifetime's worth my,
wait,
there's a bench over there.
I'll be back.